[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui loulou
dédola pour le sar d'une bande dessinée
qui se passe dans la 'ndrangheta la
mafia calabraise la plus puissante
aujourd'hui cible en ce moment même d'un
maxi procès en italie mais que l'on
connaît mal je reçois également laurent
bénégui pour son nouveau roman retour à
cuba une enquête sur sa famille aux
prises avec la révolution castriste et
le quatuor modigliani représenté par
amaury coeytaux le premier violon et le
eric loïc rio le second violon pour leur
nouvel album i'm bartok mozart et on
commence tout de suite par notre époque
qu'est ce qui caractérise ce début de
21ème siècle alors voici vos réponses en
images
on commence par la vôtre celle du
quatuor modigliani
c'est une affiche le fils du théâtre
saint-georges
c'est pour nous nous montre à quel point
ça nous manque le théâtre ou en tout cas
ça vous manque à vous et ça ne manque le
théâtre comme la com com la scène et
puis j'ai entendu récemment parlé de
noeux possible réécriture des oeuvres de
molière dans un conseil qu'il serait
plus contemporain donc j'étais assez
dubitatif pour qu'il soit soit disant le
plus accessible aux enfants
j'ai un gamin qui a huit ans qu'il a
acquis la haye découvert au théâtre et
est que je me suis surpris à re
découvrir en lisant épisode 2 la galère
la scène avec cette fameuse galère où on
allait y faire vendre c'est quoi et donc
voilà oui la scène et les plateaux et
les tréteaux quoi il a ajouté c'est
exactement ça c'est évidemment beaucoup
à nous en tant qu'artiste de pouvoir
rejoindre pluie donner des données c'est
consternant mais aussi tout simplement
aller voir les acteurs aller voir les
musées donc on appelait on attend ça
avec impatience ça va revenir moment
sinon vous allez en corée du sud à
taiwan en chine les salles de concerts
sont ouvertes il ya des concerts tous
les soirs nous voir on vit de se
confiner avec bracelet électronique dans
une chambre d'hôtel sans aucun contact
pendant 21 jours à leur relation
et c'est pas forcément la conception de
liberté d'artiste au partage c'est parce
qu'ils veulent pas qu'on leur apporte le
virus et la photo maintenant de de
laurent bénégui alors ça se fait une
couverture de disques que j'avais quand
j'étais adolescent c'est in the course
of the crimson king et sa date de 1970
je crois ouais
et bien moi ça me je trouve que cette
image m'évoque ou l'angoissé la
vocifération qui sont pour moi
malheureusement les deux choses qui sont
très présentes aujourd'hui l'angoissé
évidemment à cause de la crise sanitaire
de la montée des inégalités sociales du
bafouement des droits des femmes des
violences est en face de ça il ya plus
de débat il ya de la vocifération les
gens ne parlent plus pour être entendu
ou en tout cas il ne parle que pour
s'entendre e
les réseaux sociaux font chambre d'écho
à tout ça et donc on est dans la
vocifération on a très peu de chances de
faire progresser les idées je trouve et
les images maintenant de loulou dédola
j'ai cru reconnaître kemal atatürk et
c'est lui c'est un tableau de bélie
baïkal c'est ce peintre qui a été
poignardé par des islamistes en 2011
et ça envoie un petit peu ce qu'on vient
d'entendre les commentaires précédents a
eu un 21ème siècle qui est où on a vu
s'affronter les idéologies terrible
fascisme et le bolchévisme et c'est là
qu'a réalisme américain qui est sorti
vainqueur
on aimerait que ça se répète pas voilà
on aimerait que l'esprit de la
république l'esprit du siècle des
lumières l'esprit des présocratiques
ressurgissent et puis aussi parce que
c'est d'actualité quand même il y avait
cette phrase célèbre de kemal atatürk
qui dit que mon espoir réside dans la
jeunesse
alors où les gens s'entretuent en
banlieue on sait même plus pourquoi à
l'heure où les jeunes sont confinés
aussi c'est vrai pour protéger les lieux
qui sont de plus en plus vieux on se
demande
il faut il faut repenser moi je pense
façon je le dis souvent que le xxième
siècle sera kémaliste nous ce sera la
barbarie et bien commençons
[Musique]
et donc commencé avec vous loulou dédola
vous êtes musicien et scénariste de
bande dessinée avec le dessinateur
l'ailier aubenas corso vous publiez le
sarde aux éditions glénat une bande
dessinée qui se passe dans la mafia
calabraise la 'ndrangheta ça nous change
un peu de la mafia sicilienne et de la
camorra napolitaine dont on a épuisé les
charmes il faut bien le reconnaître
alors quel tel de différents la
n'dranghetta la grande l'état à se
distingue de la cosa nostra et donc de
la camorra parce que la cosa nostra est
dirigée par ce qu'on appelle la coupole
cinq grandes familles donc une partie
dont une famille de la mafia napolitaine
la camorra
elle se distingue par le fait qu'un sont
sa force n'est pas fondée sur sa
diaspora
c'est très bien imager dans le film de
coppola le parrain la cosa nostra c'est
d'abord des gens qui vont à ellis island
qui se retrouvent à new york ou ailleurs
et qui permettent à la cosa nostra de se
développer c'est pas du tout le cas
la dengue est à elle s'est renforcée
suite à la politique catastrophique de
toto riina qui était d'un affrontement
direct avec l'état italien est donc là
que la cosa nostra s'est beaucoup
affaibli dans cet affrontement et la
grande guetta a pu assumer le business
le plus rentable de la cosa nostra
qu'elle de trafic de stupéfiants et elle
est fondée aussi parce que c'est aussi
une réalité quand même dans la matière
faut le dire sur le courage la vaillance
de ses membres c'est des gens qui sont
capables d'aller en colombie d'aller
négocier une tonne de cocaïne avec les
gens du cartel de cali puisque
maintenant medellin est très affaibli
aussi et qu'ils sont capables de faire
passer 7,7 coke par le nigeria et
d'affronter les nigérians et cetera
mais voilà elle se distingue d'abord par
sa qu'elle n'est pas fondée par sa
diaspora et qu'elle s'appuie aussi sur
des services provider
c'est le cas de notre personnage qui est
un service provider de la grande guerre
il ya aussi une structure familiale
c'est assez forte dans la 'ndrangheta on
le voit d'ailleurs dans votre album
c'est vraiment c'est la famille et c'est
ce qui explique qu'il ya peu de repenti
il ya ce maxi procès en ce moment en
calabre 350 accusé 900 témoins 400
avocats
ça va durer deux ans mais enfin il n'y a
pas de repentis dedans ils se sont fait
choper mais c'est pas des repentis non
non il y à il ya très peu de repenti
dans la drogue d'état il est aussi très
peu dans la cosa nostra et encore une
fois c'est l'héritage de la politique de
toto riina canto taurine a fait
assassiner les enfants de ses
collaborateurs et ils fabriquent les
repentis voilà c'est le cas le film de
récents sur sur la mafia locale je crois
qu'ils racontent les problèmes que
compte générer la politique ultra bilan
de rila il s'est fait trahir après mais
la première trahison c'est de rina de
faire étrangler les enfants' et ses
collaborateurs d'assassiner les femmes
de ses collaborateurs etc
voilà donc on est dans une structure
aussi plus basé sur la famille mais
aussi sur le village c'est vraiment des
villages dans la grande guerre
c'est la plus puissante des mafias
italiennes aujourd'hui elle a des
ramifications sur les 5 continents dans
votre dans votre album on la voit
travailler en france comme en chine
ils ont sept
ils sont sont très courageux les
calabrais il faut quand même beau la
cccd conquérant aussi c'est comme quand
on parle de gengis khan dj skam disait
si tu es frayer fait le pas si tu le
fais ne soit pas effrayé et en fait ils
ont pas peur les calabrais
ils vont partout a très peu il arrive
sur le terrain et ils délèguent quand le
travail est mal fait par les personnes
qu'ils ont délégué ils savent faire
justice ils ont pas l'obsession du
massacre une vénère pas ça ils ont fait
une petite erreur je pense à duisbourg
qui les a mis sur le sur le champ devant
de la scène qui les a un peu trop
médiatisé ça ils l'ont regretté c'était
en allemagne un wallaby ce bourg de
c'est le règlement de compte il ya eu
cinq mois auraient toutes quitté pas
enfin on parle comme des mafieux la vie
des parois on parle oui essayons de
parler comme des mafieux ensemble ils
ont commis des crimes des moeurs qui
n'étaient pas nécessaires mais est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle n'a pas été
sous-estimée par par l'état italien
cette mafia parce que je crois que c'est
jusqu'en 2010 elle était même pas
considéré comme une mafia dans la loi
italienne
le maxi procès qui a lieu en ce moment
c'est parce que tout à coup ils sont
rendus compte qu'il y avait une mafia
calabraise et alors est ce que il était
dans le déni ou presque elle était très
très discrète
[Musique]
mon frère ma précédente bande dessinée
avec les lieux donne à corseaux sur le
sol et 419 gérions mille dans la rue on
savait très bien que toutes les
institutions qui arrivait par centaines
des lieux en europe n'étaient pas des
réfugiés liberian ou des réfugiés serra
les sierra léonais ski fis à la guerre
mais bien des nigérianes qui arrivait
par le 419 la mafia nigériane
la police et la justice a toujours un
temps de retard c'est mais ses parents
proches les gens fassent et c'est comme
ça voilà donc là encore une fois la
mafia a horreur du vide
quand la cosa nostra est affaibli tout
d'un coup il ya un espace ils s'en
emparent
aujourd'hui on estime son chiffre
d'affaires à la dengue est à 50
milliards d'euros par an grande partie
due au trafic de cocaïne
et c'est d'ailleurs à ce à quoi
travaille votre héros 1 et
c'est un propriétaire de restaurant
branché un producteur de musique et en
même temps un gros trafiquant de cocaïne
on le voit on va le voir dans la planche
suivante c'est ça arrive par container
en europe et il ya souvent là la
n'dranghetta derrière celle de reggio di
calabria
c'est le plus grand port de conteneurs
au monde je crois ou de rock en tout cas
il importe énormément c'est eux qui
importe la cocaïne de colombie et comme
ils sont très très forts très bien
structuré cetc des libéraux les
calabrais small is beautiful
ils y vont à la friedman ils sont petits
ils y vont mais ils font un gros
business
voilà donc il importe il importe ils
font passer sa part l'espagne font se
passer sa part le nigeria
ils font ça passait sa part les îles de
la guinée-bissau ils ont des narco état
bref ils sont ils sont très très
puissant c'est pour ça que l'italie
s'attaquer maintenant parce qu'ils sont
vraiment c'est vraiment qu occupe tout
l'espace ils ont un chiffre d'affaires
incroyable il se médiatise pas il aime
pas danser on va pas dire que j'y viens
de ces gens-là pas aussi bien des choses
parce que c'est quand même un business
terrible qui fait comme on dit dans les
quartiers font pleurer des mères qui
dont les enfants sont toxicomanes petit
les gens regardent comme le fait notre
héros des règlements de compte entre
gangs de quartier etc
c'est leur pratique mais ils sont ils
sont aussi pas intéressé par là ils sont
aussi donc contrairement aux siciliens
et qui aimait le cinéma et qu'on
produisait et qui se sont mis au devant
de l'actif d'ailleurs les bains le nom
et se scénarise pas il se met en
spectacle
mais les temps quand même bien changé
loulou dédola vous parliez du parrain
dans le parent souviens pourquoi est-ce
que marlon brando se retrouvait avec une
guerre des gangs
c'est parce qu'il avait refusé que sa
famille 30 dans le trafic de drogue il
disait que c'était pas bien le trafic de
drogue et pendant très longtemps les les
bandits au cinéma du moins ce qu'on
voulait rendre sympathique ne faisait
pas de trafic de drogue depuis un
certain nombre d'années s'est
complètement changé et les héros des
séries télé font du trafic de drogue
les héros de bandes dessinées font du
trafic de drogue c'est devenu
en liga et mean time de trafic de drogue
alors qu'est ce qui a changé
est ce que c'est le trafic de drogue qui
allait changer ou est ce que c'est parce
qu'on prend tellement de drogue en
europe qu'on a fini par trouver les
trafiquants plus sympathique que les
policiers je pense qu'ils ont été très
très peu il ya eu quelques personnes
très intelligentes qui était très bien
installé dans la cosa nostra qui ont
pensé qu'ils n'avaient pas intérêt à
développer le trafic de drogue parce que
ça allait les coupés de leur appui dans
le show business to business personnes
au même endroit mais ça l'est surtout
les couper de leurs appuis politiques
mais il est arrivé à un moment donné où
les états n'avaient plus besoin des
mafieux aussi aujourd'hui des jeunes qui
voulaient faire arrêter quelqu'un voilà
il n'est pas qu'on avait besoin de ces
gens là pour exécuter les bases aux
roues qui avaient nettoyé t entre le
pouvoir et la mafia
aujourd'hui ça a plus rien à voir il
n'en reste pas moins que tout cet argent
généré elle redonne aussi un pouvoir sur
les politiques à la drogue et à voilà
moi j'avance de la mafia et changer du
tout il ya eu des familles d'attendre
une famille à new york qui s'est opposé
au trafic de drogue et elle a été
balayée
parce que de toute façon les commerces
illégaux je veux dire la matière elle
jamais été gentil hilaire que ça soit
lui proxénétisme de vente d être une
heure ce soit du trafic d'organes du
trafic de drogue un moment s'il ya eu la
prohibition ou c'était l'alcool c'était
pas méchant c'était l'esprit qui dit
machin etc
il était une fois l'amérique mais ça
c'est quand même quelque chose de
temporaire et ce n'est pas voilà votre
héros le sarde eux se droguent lui-même
à l'héroïne est ce qu un héroïnomane
peut rester fiable et efficace dans un
système mafieux comme celui de la drôme
guetta par définition un héroïnomane
n'est pas fiable
ils n'ont pas pas dévoiler la fin de
l'histoire mais
tous les gens qui vivent dans ce milieu
là sont des gens qui ont des addictions
fait quand même pas vivre comme ça c'est
ils consomment des produits sont bien
souvent alcoolique
ils sont bien souvent ultra violent ils
ont ils ont tous des névroses
obsessionnelles ici chacun soit par jour
il y en a je prends un exemple quand
j'en ai connu c'est quinze fois par jour
et puis vous pouvez pas leur serrer la
main ou s'ils vont toujours l'impression
d'avoir les mains sales donc aujourd'hui
c'est à la mode
n'oubliez pas serré la main et tu sais
rien voilà il ya les rapports qu'ils ont
avec avec leurs enfants par exemple sont
souvent des rapports à très très bizarre
prononcées jamais lui c'est une
addiction à l'héroïne et mais elle vient
aussi de son parcours personnel un
parcours assez atypique et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'il va faire alliance
avec 14 cas la plus puissante triades
chinoises en france en plus pour truquer
des matches de foot et quand je dis
attendez là 14 calandrons guetta y soit
en france ils sont comme chez eux ils
voyagent aussi bien que le viol ça
prenne l'avion
je voudrais me dévisage non mais c'est
niet faut qu'on se dise bien que d'ici
là il vient de shanghai les tipis
imaginer qu est-ce qui peut arrêter des
gens qu'est ce qui peut empêcher des
gens qui génère 50 milliards de dollars
de chiffre d'affaires de se déplacer à
shanghai la liste rien qu'est ce qui
peut empêcher les gens de deux des
quatorze cas de faire du business avec
avec la drogue et à kehl la matière la
plus fiable
aujourd'hui la plus solide donc c'est
eux qui dominent quoi c'est lui
d'ailleurs qui heureusement qu'ils
aiment le football votre héros c'est le
c'est là où vous le rende et sympathique
au fond 1
il va se prendre d'ailleurs de passion
pour un gamin surdoué
on va pas dévoiler tout mais mais au
fond le football ça tombe bien parce que
s'ils avaient pas le football c'est
juste une ordure
parce que ça rejoint un petit peu
justement c'est là où j'espère que le
livre est intéressant ça nous renvoie ce
qu'on entend tous les jours quand on
attrape des gamins qu'on tue et d'autres
gamins quand on attrape des terroristes
et ont dit des monstres etc
moi je crois pas au monde je crois une
société qui génère des comportements il
dédouane pas les responsabilités de
chaque individu il faut combattre la
criminalité il faut combattre et
charisme attention faut bien comprendre
ce que je veux dire
mais je ne crois pas que ça soit un
monstre son parcours personnel l'amène
dans cette situation là dans cette
position vous savez c'est difficile d'en
parler en détails seront dévoilés
l'intriguent mais les homos il est au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment et en
même temps ça rejoint ce que disait
albert camus tout ce que je sais le plus
sûr sur la moralité les hommes je l' ai
appris sur un terrain de football et
c'est vrai même si aujourd'hui il
faudrait aussi en train de changer
depuis platini à la tête du football
européen
bizarrement il est tombé pour des
affaires de fraude etc
il restait quand même 40 de la pureté du
football et c'est vrai que l'huile un
peu comme albert camus il va chercher
dans le football quelque chose mais
c'est à voir
ça renvoie aussi à son passé à ce qui a
généré sont pas à la fin il va quand
même se mettre tout le monde à dos la
n'dranghetta et 14 cas là interpol et
est-ce qu'on peut encore disparaître à
d'autres époques
c'est la question que je me suis posée
en me disant heureux on dit tellement
qu'on peut plus disparaître
a fortiori quand on est recherché par
des gens pareils
puis ce qui laisse à notre sabre et
qu'est-ce que je le suis aussi
et puisque
on vous connaissez bien colonna il a
quand même réussi à sketches et pendant
un moment
il était recherché par tout le monde
voilà on peut se cacher attention on
peut se cacher si on accepte de vivre
sans internet dans une bergerie dans une
grotte entre cagliari et ça ça arrive
voilà là on peut ça y'a pas de problème
ils vont pas me trouver ils sont pas
magicien sont pas régies siens si nous
attraperait tout ce qui les gêne
voilà les policiers les grands états ils
sont aussi en difficulté des fois quand
les gens quand vous êtes milliardaire et
que vous voulez conserver notre argent
et que vous avez une attache des enfants
une famille et c'est là on vous retrouve
mais quand vous abandonner tout et vous
allez vous cacher dans une grotte ans à
revel on ne retrouve pas ou en
afghanistan
celui-ci c'est pas évident effectivement
ça s'intitule le sarde et ça vient de
paraître aux éditions glénat
[Musique]
laurent bénégui vous vous êtes l'auteur
de quatorze romans dont au petit
marguery qui vous a fait connaître du
grand public vous en aviez de tirer un
film à succès et le mari de la harpiste
pour lequel je vous avais déjà invité
dans cette émission
cette fois c'est retour à cuba qui
paraît chez julliard votre grand-père en
effet à émigrer à cuba après la guerre
de 14 il y a fait fortune
votre père et son frère sont nés à cuba
vous y êtes allé plusieurs fois rendre
visite à votre oncle et à sa famille
quand vous étiez enfant c'était le cuba
de la révolution les béni-oui-oui vivait
sur une immense propriété à côté de la
base américaine de guantanamo
de beaux souvenirs pour tous le petit
garçon que vous étiez j'imagine c'est
c'est ça qui vous a donné envie de
retourner à cuba mais travers ce livre
c'est plutôt de ne pas m'y être
intéressé plus c'est à dire que je suis
allé là bas effectivement dans les
années 68 70 en gros 10 ans après la
révolution j'ai appris à cette occasion
que j'avais un passé cubain que mon
grand-père était enterré à guantanamo
que mon père était né là bas j'avais
jamais vraiment pris conscience de ça et
j'allais là-bas parce que même ma
famille était retenue à cuba mais je
m'interrogeais pas plus que ça j'étais
gamin je serai du cheval dans la jungle
oui j'avais des très beaux souvenirs
c'est finalement récemment que je me
suis dit tiens en tant que romancier
j'ai quand même une sacrée histoire sous
la main pourquoi je m'en suis jamais
préoccupé pourquoi j'ai jamais écrit
là-dessus
alors c'est vrai que officiellement
votre oncle et sa famille vous disent
qu'ils sont retenus à cuba puisque on
leur aurait confisqué leurs passeports
leur fils aîné aurait dû aller faire son
service militaire c'est une époque où
cuba guerroyer un peu partout dans le
monde notamment en afrique et qu' il
avait déserté que donc on l'avait avait
confisqué leurs passeports
néanmoins quand vous y allez vous
souvenez que yahvé raul castro par
exemple le frère de fidel qui étaient là
sur la propriété qui tirait la cachemire
kalachnikov dans les cocotiers pour
faire tomber les noix de coco alors
c'est lui rajoute d'ailleurs là il est
tiré à la kalachnikov mais mais c'est à
peu près la tête qu'il avait quand vous
l'avez rencontrée
oui en tout cas il est jeune là c'est
sûr oui moi je dis j'allais là-bas et un
jour on me dit le monsieur important
parce que la révolution cubaine elle est
née dans l'est dans le sud-est de l'île
ce qu'on appelle lorien tc là où ma
famille avait émigré au fond d'une
cinquantaine d'années avant et il était
devenu planteurs de café dans cette
région parce que le café et pousse dans
la sierra où fidel raul et le che
guevara s'était retranché dans un
premier temps pour mener leur révolution
est donc en fait à cette occasion là
tous et tous ces révolutionnaires les
qu'on appelait les barbudos en fait il
ils mourraient de faim avant la victoire
ils n'avaient ils avaient les pieds nus
et donc il venait voir les paysans du
coin pour rançonner un poulet un cochon
est comme ça il avait rencontré connu
les membres de ma famille et donc moi
quand j'y suis allée entre temps raul
était devenu ministre des armées de la
révolution aux fidèles avaient pris le
pouvoir et ils continuent à visiter mon
oncle et raul pour m'amuser moi le petit
français tirés à la kalachnikov dans les
arbres vous allez tomber les noix de
coco il m'est très sympathique mais j'ai
encore une fois je mesurais pas vraiment
qui était cet homme est ce que ça
voulait dire j'ai enfoui tout ça
probablement parce que ça en traînés
beaucoup de confusion dans ma famille et
de déchirement donc j'ai mis tout ça
sous de mouchoirs pendant très longtemps
avant de me rendre compte qu'il fallait
sérieusement que je comprenne ce qui
s'était passé et ce que voulait dire le
fait qu'ils étaient retenus à cuba c'est
à dire qu en fait une des premières
décision prise par par castro et son
gouvernement c'est la nationalisation
des terres et donc un jour les
militaires sont arrivés chez chez
l'oncle chesnais oncle et leur ont dit
voilà cette terre que vous cultivez
depuis 60 ans ces dizaines d'hectares de
café ce n'est plus à vous allez les
partager avec vos ouvriers et donc c'est
comme ça du jour au lendemain ils sont
retrouvés ouvriers sur leurs propres
plantations puis ne pouvant plus même
quitté l'île privée de passeport
ma grand mère à l'époque a alerté tous
les ministres des affaires étrangères de
tous les gouvernements de de de gaulle
pompidou giscard pour qu'ils aient si
ils soient enfin relâché un jour voilà
va vous êtes quand même dans votre
génération vous n'êtes pas nombreux fans
d'un autre génération n'est pas on épile
sont pas nombreux ceux qui ont été à
cuba à la grande époque qu'un celle de
la révolution romantique avant qu'on on
nous montre cuba sous un autre jour mais
à l'époque ce qui est un peu le rendez
vous de la jet set internationale cuba
dans les années 60 on fait une pause
laurent bénégui on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec laurent
bénégui qui publie retour à cuba
chez julliard et
c'est vrai que c'est un livre la foi qui
tient de l' enquête sur le passé
familial
et puis surtout un livre sur cuba mais
reste en un instant sur sur l' enquête
familiale en 1977
votre famille cubaine le frère de votre
père sa femme et ses deux enfants ont pu
enfin sortir de cuba sont arrivés en
france sans un sou vous les avez hébergé
chez vous à l'époque vous habitiez
c'était le temps du petit marguery
célèbre restaurant vous avez raconté
l'histoire dans un roman est dans un
film
et puis votre père et son frein se sont
fâchés et ils ne se sont plus jamais
adressé la parole
c'est aussi ça qui fait que vous avez
envie de revenir sur le passé de
comprendre pourquoi ils se sont fâchés à
l'époque
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement et
je me demande toujours pourquoi revient
ton sur le passé familial est ce que
vous seriez revenu sur ce passé familial
s'il n'y avait pas eu cuba s'il n'y
avait pas eu la fortune des bd guy au
fond qu'est-ce qui vous attire pas là
dedans c'est l'exotisme et l'argent
alors sûrement pas l'argent je pense que
je suis revenue là dedans peut-être pour
transmettre la vérité à mes filles je me
suis dit que j'avais vécu longtemps et
dans l'ignorance volontaire de ce qui
s'était vraiment passé et dans un
refoulement et qu'il était temps pour
moi d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi mon
père et son frère
ils ont été séparés toute leur vie par
un océan et puis lorsque mon oncle est
revenu à paris effectivement hébergé
chez nous en quelques mois et se sont
déchirés disputer et comprendre pourquoi
et qui avait raison au fond quand nos
parents se disputent
on a tendance à donner à leur donner
raison pas écouter l'autre partie je
parlais tout à l'heure de la lave aussi
su de la vocifération de la difficulté
de de débattre c'est exactement ça je me
suis dit mais mon père et son frère au
fond ils n'ont jamais débattu ils se
sont très vite insulté puis tu donc j'ai
eu envie de savoir s'il y'avait parce
que il ya ce que j'appelle dans le roman
l'hypothèse du magot puisqu'on a eu une
propriété puisqu'on a été riche avant
que fidel castro ne nationalisent tous
passer quelques dizaines d'années vous
savez que les cubains y en a beaucoup
qui ont émigré en floride il ya quelques
comptes en banque à miami qui ont été
alimentées des années par les cubains
donc je me suis dit à hu nous sommes dit
dans la famille il ya eu de l'argent
pendant des années alors où est passé
cet argent
moi c'était pas du tout pour le pour le
récupérer très honnêtement je pense que
s'il y avait quelque chose à récupérer
ce serait peut-être ses terres où quand
même il ya eu un siècle de vie de ma
famille voilà ce serait plutôt agréable
de se dire qu'on peut retourner là bas
l'argent c'est pas très important au
fond je me suis si ce n'est que ma grand
mère qui était la véritable propriétaire
de cette aire n'en a jamais vu qu'elle a
vécu dans la pauvreté toute sa vie
j'aurais aimé pouvoir peut-être qu'on
veut réparer ça mais c'est pas ma
motivation personnelle la motivation
si j'en avais eu une derrière outre
l'écriture c'était au fond transmettre
transmettre saint amé fille il ya des
gens de ma famille depuis plus d'un
siècle à cuba je n'ai pas envie que ça
s'arrête comme ça en tout cas ce sera à
elle de choisir je parle du destin les
anguilles puisque au fond ma famille
c'est toujours balader entre le
sud-ouest de la france et cuba et les
anguilles c'est sont ces poissons qui
pondent dans la mer des sargasses les
alevins remonte remontant la rivière des
pyrénées puis après ils refont le chemin
inverse je me suis tu y en a un destin
en billes je mette mes filles sur ce
chemin dans ce courant là et puis
c'était une manière d'avoir ça à leur
raconter mais dans votre livre on se
plonge dans cuba et moi je suis allé
souvent à cuba et c'est une île que
j'adore j'adore cuba j'adore les cubains
néanmoins on est toujours fasciné par il
ya une esthétique cubaine ain mais cette
esthétique je parle celle des villes
comme la havane on va voir des images au
fond c'est un mélange d'architecturé
coloniale espagnole
et puis de d'esthétique américaine a
porté par la mafia là on est dans les
esthétiques coloniale espagnole
c'est le théâtre au centre de la havane
mais mais tous tous ces hôtels l'hôtel
riviera l'hôtel national tout ça c'est
beaucoup plus ce qu'on voit le nom du
malecon à ce son
beaucoup plus là c'est celle et mafieux
qui les ont construits pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux ou qu'ils en étaient
propriétaires notamment pendant la
dictature de batista et aux fausses
qu'on aime
esthétiquement à cuba je me suis
toujours dit c'est pas du tout le régime
castriste qui lui quand il s'est mis à
construire des trucs c'était plutôt
horrible d'ailleurs au fond c'est les
espagnols et les américains quand m
il est conclu pour les voitures à devant
cuba et célèbreront les voitures
américaines des années 50 qui roule
toujours là bas puisqu'ils en ont pas
d'autre nos fautes ça en corse a aussi
cette amérique
oui pourtant castro a eu un effet qu'il
n'attendait pas il a sauvé on ne sait
pas en fait une grande patrie du parti
pardon du patrimoine architectural de de
la havane de la vieille ville qui est
justement ce vestige de la présence
espagnole où tous ces immeubles sont
magnifiques
castro l'a sauvée sans le savoir
distin juste avant que la révolution
advienne voulait fourguer tout ce
patrimoine aux mafieux pour qu'ils
construisent d'autres quartiers et à
partir du moment où castro a fait sa
révolution a gagné à chasser les les
mafieux ce tout le vieux quartiers de la
havane du coup n'est pas passé entre les
mains des promoteurs
alors il l'a il s'est usé 1 c ses
façades sont à la fois sublime et
certaines sont des crépis comme des
vieilles dentelles qui serait ré qui se
fond est restée qui sont d'ailleurs
restés des siècles comme ça sans
entretien
mais la révolution de castro a permis de
sauver une grosse partie du patrimoine
je pense pas que c'était son objectif
premier mais de fait
oui mais il ya peu de construction sous
castro très vite ils ont pas eu d'argent
ils ont pas ils n'avaient plus très vite
de quoi faire du béton donc mais c'est
aussi pour ça que les hommes les parties
ans ils en ont récupéré avec l'ouverture
au tourisme dont 92 quand l'urss a cessé
de deux mètres cubes à sous perfusion il
a bien fallu trouver des devises ils ont
fait venir des touristes
et c'est avec cet argent ils ont pu non
seulement restaurer toute cette vieille
ville
de la havane mais en plus commencer à
construire quelques horreurs qui ont
déformé le malecon donc c'est bien
qu'ils se soient arrêtées là enfin je
suis pas revenue récemment vous vous y
êtes retourné l'année dernière juste
avant juste avant que nous confine ça a
dû bien changé la vanne notamment en ça
a changé
alors ce qui est incroyable c'est qu'il
ya des choses qu'on a absolument pas
bougé depuis un demi siècle
moi j'ai retrouvé je suis repassé sur
tous les endroits où j'avais été
autrefois rien n'a changé moi c'est
toujours ce sentiment là bas d'un
certain immobilisme
ce qui a changé c'est que la situation
des gens là bas est absolument terrible
lavagne est une petite enclave où
arrivent encore un peu d'essence
mais j'ai eu des échanges par très
récemment avec des cubains entre le
durcissement de la politique de donald
trump qui a essayé de se faire élire
dans les besoins de la floride donc
savait que les exilés cubains en floride
de vote pour contre contre castro donc
quand on veut gagner quand on est un
président américain qu'on veut gagner
les élections il faut remporter il faut
plaire aux cubains de miami dont il faut
durcir le ton et augmenté les sanctions
sur cuba donc en ce moment ils crèvent
de faim ils n'ont pas d'essence
[Musique]
il ya un vrai risque de famine par
exemple le manque de nourriture est
telle qu'ils peuvent même plus dans les
campagnes nourrir leurs animaux donc
après donc il peut même plus manger dans
un hymne au merlan laurent bénégui
trempe y travailler pour vous parce que
ce que veulent les cubains de miami est
ce que trempent leur promettait c'était
la restitution de leurs terres
nationalisées par castro oui les
américains
vous auriez peut-être pu récupérer les
vôtres vrai show américain fabrique sous
la mer 5 1 mais honnêtement c'est vrai
c'est curieux c'est c'est peut-être pour
ça que j'ai écrit le livre je n'ai pas
du tout de personnellement 2
dans vie de récupérer des terres ou de
l'argent par rapport à ça c'est comme si
j'avais tout mis dans le livre est est
ce que vous allez aussi recommencer
est-ce que vous avez au moins récupérer
les est-ce que vous avez percer tous les
secrets de famille
est ce que vous savez aujourd'hui est ce
que vous êtes sûr de savoir où est passé
l'argent pourquoi vous vous votre père
et son oncle et son frère se sont
disputés de la sorte pourquoi votre
cousin ne veut toujours pas vous voir
j'ai pas ils regardent peut-être
l'émission alors pourquoi ils se sont
disputés oui parce que mon père était
persuadé que qu'ils avaient de l'argent
qu'il n'avait donc jamais donné à leur
mère ma grand mère et ils se sont fâchés
à cause de ça ce qu'il y avait
énormément d'argent own opinion on sait
qu'ils n'avaient pas tant que ça et
qu'au fond ils se sont enfin chamailler
c'était plus que ça mais un conflit
d'ego de l'année confie d'argent s'est
transformé en conflit d'ego qui avait
une telle différence après avoir vécu
tant d'années dans l'acier rhin et par
rapport à des gens qui avaient vécu en
france dans les années 60 70 80 90 une
telle différence de mentalité que que le
il ya eu un véritable une déflagration
entre eux c'est pas très important que
je n'ai pas répondu à toutes les
questions parce que ce qui m'importait
c'était plus le trajet que la
destination
ce que j'ai fait c'est quand je suis
arrivé là bas et où j'ai retrouvé
l'ancienne propriété ou plutôt le ce
qu'il en reste dans la dans la brousse
de la sierra je suis tombé sur une
petite plaque métallique en espagnol
marqué propriété militaire
j'en ai déduit donc dans les années 60
cette ferme qui appartenait à mon grand
père avait été transformée en une espèce
d'endroit pour les militaires et j'ai
piqué la plaque
voilà donc c'est ça qui me reste c'est
une petite plaque métallique que j'ai
volé à l'état cubain qui doit dater kg
trouvaient au fond de la jungle
vous savez qu ils ont le vaccin ils ont
un vaccin en tout cas les cubains qu'ils
ont mis au point tout seul
ils ont éradiqué le bienvenu
c'est maintenant qu'il faudrait y
retourner un an ils ont pendant trop tôt
indiqué non les nouvelles que j'ai c'est
que ça va pas du tout à ce niveau là ah
bon ils sont ils sont ils sont très très
bons au niveau médical parce qu'ils ont
c'est une forme de propagande ils
exportent très très bien des médecins
près de pointu je pense qu'ils sont
capables tout à fait de d'avoir un
accent sur les skis ski ce qu'ils disent
ce qui se dit là bas c'est la révolution
cubaine a eu 3 3 succès et trois échecs
par le premier les trois succès c'est
rendre sa fierté au peuple cubain
le deuxième succès c'est la lutte contre
l'analphabétisme et le troisième succès
c'est les soins médicaux et donc pas
répondre à ce qu'on vient de dire et les
trois échecs c'est le petit déjeuner le
déjeuner et le dîner parce qu'il n'y a
rien à manger et donc ils ont beaucoup
d'humour les cubains et c'est un peuple
qui a incroyablement drôle avec aussi un
grand fatalisme
je me disais en voyant les que
aujourd'hui ici devant tous les magasins
à cause des conditions sanitaires qu'on
arrive on se comporte aujourd'hui comme
les cubains à cuba dès qu'un magasin est
ouvert s'il ya un pauvre paquet de
lessive ya 200 personnes qui font la
queue ils sont extrêmement discipliné et
en gueule pas et nous on est en train de
vivre un petit peu la cubaine en ce
moment on fait la queue relativement de
manière relativement disciplinés et je
pensais aussi par rapport à ce qu'on
disait sur la mafia juste avant et à
l'incroyable influence qu'a toujours eue
l'île de cuba sur l'élection des
présidents américains puisque ou après
la révolution et après que castro et
donné des coups de pied aux fesses des
mafieux qui avait donc construit tout ce
patrimoine architectural et les hôtels à
cuba eux n'ont eu cesse que de récupérer
leur bien et ils ont cofinancé avec la
cia tout à l'heure on disait que à une
époque la mafia est une sorte d' alliée
des états mais oui ils ont cofinancé aux
états unis certains mouvements le
débarquement de la baie des cochons et
où il se dit il se fait plus que se
murmurait que comme ils ont trouvé que
kennedy n'avait pas été suffisamment
efficace dans son soutien et pour la
réussite du débarquement de la baie des
cochons qui aurait dû
mettre fin au régime de castro c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles il a été
supprimé
c'est ce qu'on dit effectivement eu
retour à cuba le nouveau livre de
laurent bénégui vient de paraître chez
julliard
[Musique]
alors amaury coeytaux à droite et loïc
rio à gauche vous êtes respectivement
premier et second violon du célèbre
quatuor modigliani qui sort un nouvel
album i'm bartok mozart on regarde tout
de suite la bande-annonce qui vient de
sortir sur internet
[Musique]
l'idée originale effectivement de ce
disque c'était de réunir trois
compositeurs emblématique qui sont
mozart haydn bartok mais aussi trois
chefs-d'oeuvre chacun d'entre eux qui
correspondent à une période de leur vie
particulière pour hayden c'est un moment
où ils quittent où il s'affranchit du
conte gasterra d'hygiène une liberté il
retrouve cette passion et ce coup de
crayon vraiment ludique
pour mozart c'est une époque où se
replonge dans tout un tas de manuscrits
livres découvre en fait ils découvrent
même l'art baroque et notamment jean
sébastien bach il fume beaucoup de
changements on entend ça de façon
absolument inouïe dans ces dissonances
si connue
[Musique]
on
unis
bartok et également un compositeur très
important pour nous quartz et il a écrit
un cycle qui prend une place et une
grande dimension toute la musique du
xxème siècle il revient beaucoup at war
après deux ans d'absence
une écriture et c'est le quatuor qui va
lui donner un moyen d'expression où il
utilise beaucoup de thèmes folkloriques
avec également un langage classique
maintenant il a mis quelques années
avant de se remettre à la composition et
pour nous c'est aussi touchant que ceux
ci soient remis avec l'écriture de quoi
toi au troisième puis ensuite le 4ème le
le répertoire du quatuor à cordes est
extrêmement étendue la plupart des
grands compositeurs on composait pour
les quatuors à cordes
pourquoi comment l'expliquez vous
pourquoi un tel succès ces spots
d'accord qui va répondre c'est un micro
laboratoire pour et puis c'est juste
quatre musiciens c'est facile à réunir
surtout aujourd'hui facilement à 4
encore plus aujourd'hui
marquez a coûté beaucoup plus cher aux
programmateurs organisateurs donc
donc on a pu en composés par le passé
de nombreux et c'était également des
oeuvres qui était jouée à l'époque de
haydn par les amateurs qui allait faire
une partie de côtoieront qu'ils
attendaient la sortie des six nouveaux
opus qui sortait par catalogue de l'ailé
dernier de mozart haydn dochter d'autres
ainsi de suite et puis la salle de
concert arrive en 19e siècle on a pu
projeter un peu plus le son et les
compositeurs avec ses moyens
d'expression a ses limites et finalement
passé final que quatre instruments 16
cordes
ouais c'est réussi la prouesse d'écrire
des chefs-d'oeuvre comme les 15 de haydn
qui sont sur ce disque ou les retours
des dissonances de mozart et est ce que
ce sont quatre voies différentes
kiki qui joue dans un quatuor amaury
coeytaux votre partition est totalement
différente de celle de loïc ou de celle
de du violoncelliste ou de l'alto oui
bien sûr elles viennent toutes se
complétaient comme disait loïc ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est qu'avec ces
quatre voies il ya tout un éventail de
couleurs tout un éventail de caractère
qui sont possibles et tout ça vient
sambre s'imbriquer de façon assez
magique après suivant la période
voilà quand on a le haydn c'est vrai que
le premier violon à une on va dire une
belle part du gâteau avec beaucoup de
thèmes et des mis très en avant et après
c'est toute cette subtilité sur les
trois voies qui sont plus proches les
unes des autres et qui vont donner
toutes ses couleurs après plus tard 19e
quand on joue un quatuor de brasse c'est
quelque chose de très équilibré où
chacun se partagent les thèmes et g et
voyage d'une dune d'une voix d'autres
etc heine qui qui est avec lui que ça
commence le catcheur accorde on dit que
c'est le père du quatuor à cordes no
d'accord dit que c'est le père c'est le
premier à avoir composé des
chefs-d'oeuvre au genre des oeuvres qui
qui qui sont
sont connus joué quasiment tous les
jours et encore aujourd'hui et qui va
motiver aussi incroyablement mozart qui
va lui dédier six quatuors dont les dans
les glissements siby écrit je t'ai écrit
ces quads fort ils sont comme mes fils
et ce qui est finalement les pour les
compositeurs écrire pourquoi trois
cordes c'est également un challenge de
virtuosité d'écriture parce que il n'y a
pas qu'à une harpe d'un livre avec l'art
une artiste il n'y a pas deux a en effet
de deux corps un effet de flûte pour qui
nous servira d'artifice on est
complètement sur un fil tout le temps et
donc il faut créer son propre univers
avec ses potes fois chez bartok donc un
siècle après plus d'un siècle après là
on adore seul avec ces mêmes instruments
classiques un qui moi je vois seulement
aujourd'hui de 1780 il arrive à
retranscrire tout une forme de musique
populaire de sa pays de son pays
d'origine la roumanie ce passé qui était
un monstre on rit aussi puis puis
d'aider musique kabyle parfois des des
retranscriptions dans un langage entre
guillemets d'apprendre de musique
occidentale
justement vous voyez là on voit m il a
41 ans quand il rencontre mozart qui
n'en a que 17
c'est une star énorme en europe il est
la coqueluche de toutes les cours
européennes
et puis voit débarquer ce ce jeune
garçon de 17 ans est ce que j'aime
beaucoup chez heinz et qu'en dépit de sa
son âge et sa et de sa célébrité
il reconnaît le génie de mozart et il
est il tombe en admiration devant
beaux-arts c'est c'est faire preuve de
beaucoup d'humilité quand même mais tout
à fait mais après on avait affaire un
météore qui qui qui arrivait comme celle
qui avait son son langage à lui qui
avait tout assimiler en si peu de temps
des techniques d'écriture les plus
modernes déséquilibres des balances les
des plans sonores
c'était assez amusant pour nous de jouer
dans la période entre les deux
confinement de nos salles de concert
mais on a eu la chance de les jouer à
esterhazy là où réside et hayden
certainement d'en parler dans l'une des
salles ont dû être créés c'est quoi toi
et c'est vrai qu'on sent qu'il ya
toujours eu un
ils ont toujours eu une amitié
réciproque et se stimuler les uns les
autres
après avec ben et hop c'est légèrement
différent parce que hayden va vivre
longtemps et comme une bête offre arrive
là on sent qu'il ya plus de rivalité et
finalement les derniers quatuors que
composera il donne dix ans à savoir
correspondre à la même période ou b
tough composent les six premiers et
finalement l'un abdiquera finalement
pour le cdh après sa mort le chrétien
modigliani vous faites partie des rares
musiciens aiment d'affaires de crossover
vous nos registres et pas de mu de
morceaux pop ou de musiques de films
pour séduire le grand public
pourquoi vous croyez ça vulgaire
non simplement je pense et il faut bien
le faire d'une part c'est pas c'est pas
évident nous on en a déjà beaucoup à
faire aujourd'hui on travaille sur une
intégrale de coacher de schubert il ya
quinze quatuor apprend qu'ils sont
extraordinaires et tout simplement on
peut pas un peu pas s'éparpiller c'est
comme une conne disait loïc ce qui est
incroyable dans le quatuor c'est que
deux avec si peu de matériaux comme il
n'ya pas d'artifices il ya une sincérité
c'est pas si on peut dire absolue mais
en tout cas qui ils font ça va vraiment
toujours à l'essentiel et ce travail là
pour nous aider journalier on en a même
besoin fort ça c'est une petite drogue
pour nous et voilà on en est vraiment
dévoués à cette tâche quelque part ce
que j'ai trouvé dans votre répertoire
qui est très large maintenant vous avez
sorti beaucoup d'albums avec beaucoup de
succès d'ailleurs
mais ce que vous avez fait de plus
populaire c'est le sait l'adagio pour
cordes de semelle barbe
or là tout à coup vous touchez à un tube
de la mesure musique classique basque y
en a aussi des tubes de la musique
classique
c'est le cas de l'adagio de barber on en
écoute un extrait et on se dit mais au
fond il pourrait jouer aussi eu aussi du
ennio morricone hérons des coûts de
barber damas
[Musique]
cet adagio pour cordes il a été écrit
également pour un quatuor à cordes
justement voilà un poney plus la version
un peu pour orchestre de chambre qui a
été joué pour les funérailles de
présidents américains et qui est qui et
qui est très connu qui est notre
populaire mais son origine c'est le
mouvement d'un quatuor entre mouvements
de samuel barber et voilà c'est le
quatuor est un peu à l'origine de
beaucoup de d'expérience
d'expérimentation pour l'épauler pour
les compositeurs également dans les
formes dans l'est dans les dents les
l'agencement des mouvements et les
ressert parfois de petits laboratoires
merci tous les deux à une barque toc
mozart c'est le titre du nouvel album du
quatuor me lydie modigliani fut merci à
tous les quatre évidemment merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]